what i want to do in this video is show
you that for loops aren't the only types
of loops you would use although they
probably are the most common you could
also use something like a while loop and
maybe the while loop might be more
intuitive at least maybe in the python
context you can pick so i'm going to
write the same program it's going to do
the exact same thing but instead of
using a for loop i'm going to use a
while loop so i'm going to still start
with the sum equals 0 but i'm also going
to start with i equal to 0.
so the while loop isn't going to
automatically define what my i values
are and it's not going to automatically
change my i values for me i'm going to
have to do that for myself but i want to
do the exact same the exact same
behavior and i'm going to leave my old
code down here so you can compare it a
little bit but then i'll delete it
because i don't want the same thing to
be run twice so i'm going to set i equal
to 0
and this in case you're curious the last
time in the for loop i is only a valid
variable inside the loop now i'm
defining it outside of the loop so it's
actually a global variable i'm defining
it at the highest level it can be used
anywhere inside of the program
and so over here
let's define a while loop
so while so i'm going to keep doing what
what's inside of the loop clause i'm
going to do it while i is less than 10.
remember we want it for we want to do it
for i equals 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9.
everything up to but not including 10
all of the 0 through 9. so while is
while i is less than 10.
do what i'm going to put in this clause
once i is not less than 10 or
essentially once y i is equal to 10
don't do it anymore so it's going to
have the same behavior as this right
over here and what i'm going to do is
i'm going to say sum
is equal to sum plus i
is equal to sum plus i
and then i'm going to print some
so this is the exact same logic that i
had when i wrote the for loop but i'm
going to have to add one more line here
if i don't want this thing to run
forever because right here in the for
loop remember every time we run this
clause here as we get out of the clause
it'll assign i to the next element in
this list year over here we haven't
defined how i should change so what we
have to do is
through in every loop we have to
increase the value of i so we could say
i is equal to
i
i plus 1. and i want you to really think
about how these are equivalent how both
of these these are equivalent things i
started at 0 before i even entered into
this loop
and then i'm going to and some start at
0 for either of these you say sum is
equal to sum plus i well that's the same
print sum now over here i will then once
we go through this loop in the for loop
i will then be assigned to the next the
next element in this list which is 1.
over here there's nothing to say to do
that so we're just going to say i is now
going to be the previous i which is 0
and add 1 to it and these are equivalent
because each of these elements in this
list in range of 10 that we defined are
just one more than the previous one so
instead we could just say hey i is going
to be one more than it was before and so
this should produce the exact this
should produce the exact same result and
actually if i don't want to get rid of
this code if i want it there just for
future reference but i don't want the
interpreter the python interpreter to
run it i could comment them out and you
comment things out by putting a little
hash sign there so a hash sign there
that literally says hey interpreter
ignore all of this stuff and it could be
useful if you have some code in there
that you want to just not be interpreted
for now and maybe you want to save it
for later and it's also useful if you
want to tell someone who's actually
reading the code if you want to tell a
human being who's reading the code what
this code does so for example you could
write you could write a little comment
here
what did i do what is that thing you
could write a little comment here that
says this while loop
this while loop calculates
calculates the sum of 0
0 through 9 and you'd say including 9
including including 9. so if someone
were to come back later instead of them
having to try to figure out what this
says they could read your comments say
okay this part this part of the code
right here calculates the sum of 0 to 9
and i could say and places it and places
and places
it so when you put this hashtag it
essentially comments out that line so if
i want to go to another line i have to
put another hashtag there and places it
in the variable in the variable sum so
then people know what i know what it's
doing and i know that when all is said
and done that this the sum will be
placed in this variable called sum but
anyway let's run this program and one
show that it ignores these things if you
wrote these this text without a hashtag
the computer the interpreter say what is
all this this isn't python code but this
is useful for someone else reading and
it'll also ignore this down here so
let's
let's uh i can delete this
delete that line right over there and
then let's save it
let's save it and then let's run it and
show it gives you the exact same results
that we got before
so let me run it so these are the
results that we got before you might
remember 0 1 3 6 10 all the way up to
45. now let's run this thing assuming
that i haven't made any bugs
and i get the exact same thing i get the
exact same thing so this while loop is
doing the exact same thing it's just
doing a little bit it's more explicitly
defining i i guess it takes a little bit
more code to write it but it's exact
same behavior